e
[Música]
[Aplausos]
eu vivo no lugar do meio e quando eu
digo isso para vocês não é porque eu tô
aqui no meio desse tapete eu sempre Vivi
nesse lugar Um lugar entre oportunidade
necessidade entre riqueza e pobreza e um
lugar que não por mera coincidência eu
ainda muito pequena considerei como
mundo de branco e mundo de negro e aí eu
queria uma teoria na minha cabeça do que
que era esse lugar porque por muito
tempo eu não sabia que esse lugar também
era ocupado por outras pessoas negras e
eu considerava que o lugar do Meio era
na verdade o lugar nenhum
mas depois de alguns anos de terapia e
muitas conversas eu descobri que na
verdade o lugar do meio também era o meu
propósito de vida não só o meu mas o da
minha irmã eu sou filha de dois
ex-professores minha mãe a história de
escola pública tanto da rede estadual
quanto da Prefeitura e o meu pai também
já foi professor de cursinho mas depois
ele conseguiu passar no concurso para
vestibular fazer faculdade de engenharia
mais tarde ele largou Engenharia e foi
fazer direito bom e os meus pais eram
duas pessoas negras que nasceram na
década de 40 e quando quase nenhum negro
conseguia se formar e conciliar Estudo e
trabalho os meus pais conseguiram e isso
fez com que eles ocupassem lugares que
na terra então pouquíssimos negros
ocupavam
e
por conta desta realidade que os meus
pais viveram eles fizeram uma escolha
para mim para minha irmã eles decidiram
que ao invés da gente estudar em escolas
públicas eles iam colocar a gente nos
melhores colégios particulares da cidade
que a gente morava
Oi e essa escolha foi determinante na
minha vida porque eu sei que foi a
melhor escolha que eles poderiam ter
feito para mim porque essa escolha me
deu muitas oportunidades mas também foi
onde eu conheci o esse lugar que é o
lugar do meio
e lá pelos meus 7 anos é eu comecei a
perceber que as crianças do meu bairro
não iam lá muito com a minha cara e eu
entendi que eles não iam com a minha
cara porque eu estudava num colégio
chique meu colégio tinha duas piscinas
aquecidas 9 quadras poliesportivas aula
de computação em 1997 além de aulas de
inglês e várias outras atividades
extracurriculares e isso fazia com que
eu fosse considerada a Paty eu
patricinha lá no meu bairro
e ao mesmo tempo você é uma das poucas
crianças negras no colégio de 3.000
alunos me fazem entender que para
algumas pessoas eu não devia estar ali
e é eu lembro bem de alguns alunos ou
pais de alunos que ele me perguntavam se
eu era filha do Luiz Aldo Miranda o Luis
era porteiro do colégio e o Miranda era
disciplinário ambos eram negros e o Luiz
tinha três filhos que eram bolsistas no
colégio então toda vez que me
perguntavam isso parecia que eu não
podia estar ali pagando eu precisava ter
uma bolsa para estudar naquele Colégio E
todas as vezes que essa pergunta vinha
dos Meus Amiguinhos no colégio eu sempre
respondia eu adoro Luis mas ele não é
meu pai meu pai paga Colégio igual o seu
pai paga para você
ao mesmo tempo eu também frequentava
outros espaços brancos e que pareciam
que eu não era bem recebida ali eu
lembro que uma vez eu fui para um
restaurante com a minha família inteira
Meu pai minha mãe meus primos meus tios
e a gente vai para o restaurante chique
lá de BH como Toda Boa Família mineira a
gente comeu bebeu e se divertiu e não
era uma conta grande então no final
desse desse almoço que a gente teve
quando a gente vai pagar a conta o
gerente educadamente chegou e perguntou
se a gente era alguma comitiva de algum
país africano Eu lembro que eu tinha 10
anos e eu nunca mais esqueci porque
parecia aqui para eu estar naquele lugar
com a minha família gastando dinheiro
com comida e bebida eu tinha que ser
gringa eu não podia ser simplesmente uma
mulher negra e brasileira
E durante anos eu senti e vivenciei em
silêncio o que era tá no lugar que
parecia esse lugar do meio e na verdade
um lugar de não pertencimento
parecia que eu era boa demais para estar
com os meus amigos do bairro que não
tiveram oportunidade de estudo iguais
que eu tive mas ao mesmo tempo eu não
era boa o suficiente para ocupar aquele
espaço dentro de uma escola totalmente
elitista
mas o engraçado se eu posso dizer assim
é que dentro da escola eu fingir
anormalidade aqueles lugar do incômodo
não era incômodo de jeito nenhum porque
eu era melhor uma das melhores alunas da
sala eu fazia parte do grupo de dança do
grupo de atletismo eu era super Popular
a Representante de Turma
era da comissão de formatura e ai de
quem falasse que aquele espaço não era
meu mas
o tempo no bairro o afastamento foi se
tornando O isolamento E se eu pegar hoje
para lembrar eu realmente não tenho
praticamente nenhum amigo do bairro eu
tenho apenas uma amiga e ela é branca
porque tem isso também eu só fui ter os
meus amigos negros depois que eu sair do
colégio e foi entrar numa universidade
e essa foi a minha vivência dos 4 aos 18
anos eu vivia naquele lugar do meio e
que muitas vezes Ele pareceu Solitário
Mas tinha uma pessoa que sabe exatamente
o que eu passava e vivenciava isso
comigo que era minha irmã que também
estudava no colégio e creio que passava
pelas mesmas coisas que eu
então para mim hoje é muito
natural
entender porque que a minha irmã se
tornou minha melhor amiga e sócia de
trabalho porque naquele lugar do meio eu
só tinha ela com quem eu me identificava
com quem eu podia trocar essa vivência E
essas histórias
e apesar de eu e a Isa minha irmã sempre
estamos super envolvidas com a arte
desde pequena a gente dançava fazer balé
desde os três anos a arte nunca foi uma
opção para a gente como profissão eu
acho que para negros que vivem em cima
esse lugar do meio a gente tem uma
obrigação de prosperar financeiramente e
talvez ter um status social ainda maior
Então muitos acabam escolhendo
faculdades tradicionais como medicina ou
direito eu e minha irmã a gente acabou
escolhendo algumas coisas mais
alternativas eu fiz relações públicas e
ela Turismo é mas foi só quando eu me
mudei para o rio em 2014 que eu entendi
que o lugar do meio também era o meu
propósito Eu me mudei para o Rio
querendo trabalhar com arte cultura e de
repente me vi trabalhando com artistas
negros e periféricos pessoas que eram
ainda mais desprovidos de oportunidades
do que as crianças que moravam lá no meu
bairro com pessoas como Mc Carol eu
entendi que para muitas dessas crianças
entrar na faculdade não era uma opção
uma possibilidade não porque elas não
queriam Mas por que o ensino não é de
qualidade e também não é porque eu todos
os professores como meu pai e minha mãe
mas sim por conta de um sistema que não
prioriza a educação e não prioriza os
educadores
e eu também entendi que muitas dessas
crianças não tinham um exemplo de outras
coisas que elas poderiam ser os pais
delas acabavam vivenciando uma única
realidade E essa era a realidade que ela
tinha um contato então muitas vezes elas
achavam que um crescer e virará
empregadas domésticas ou fazer algum
trabalho braçal e não que isso seja
menos ou que não seja Digno mas essas
crianças têm um mundo de possibilidades
que elas nem sabem que têm porque ela
simplesmente não tem um exemplo ou para
quem olhar e ver e falar eu posso ser
isso também
Oi E para completar eu entendi que
muitos dos negros ainda não conseguiram
quebrar um ciclo vivido pelos nossos
antepassados simplesmente porque eles
não tiveram oportunidades de fazer essa
quebra como eu tive na verdade como meus
pais tiveram e proporcionaram isso para
mim talvez talvez não com certeza se os
meus avós não tivessem incentivado os
meus pais a estudar em conciliar em
Estudo e trabalho numa época que as
escolas estaduais ainda era o melhor
tipo de ensino que você podia ter
meus pais não teriam se formado em
faculdades e não poderiam ter
proporcionado essa vida para mim e para
minha irmã então eu fico pensando que
essas escolhas e oportunidades que os
meus avós e os meus pais tiveram foi o
que me trouxe aqui hoje e se essas
pessoas não têm essas oportunidades não
tem a possibilidade dessa escolha como
que elas vão quebrar esse ciclo G1
e hoje eu e a Isa minha irmã nós somos
sócias a gente criou uma produtora para
trabalhar com esses artistas negros e
periféricos em maioria mulheres negras
que eram cheios de talentos e
possibilidades mas que muitas vezes não
sabiam como chegar em outras esferas é
como se o mundo periférico e o mundo do
dinheiro das riquezas eles não se
encontrassem alguém precisasse fazer um
intercâmbio um link Entre esses mundos E
aí que entram as pessoas do lugar do
meio
e como a própria Carol fala É como se a
favela falaste com a beleza e o mundo de
dinheiro dos negócios falar se o juiz de
que se e a gente precisasse de pessoas
para fazer o dinheiro circular na
periferia e levar a arte da Periferia
para outros lugares inclusive para
própria Elite
e eu reparei que quando não são pessoas
com vivências parecidas com as minhas
trabalhando com esses artistas duas
coisas tendem a acontecer a primeira é
que esses artistas sozinhos não
conseguem transcender a sua bolha eu e o
seu mundo então sua arte não pode chegar
em muitos outros lugares
Oi e a segunda coisa é que muitas vezes
a arte pode até transcender o mundo da
Periferia mas quando não são pessoas no
lugar do meio que estão fazendo essa
interseção os artistas acabam sendo
enganados por pessoas que sabem que eles
não sabem o juridiquês não sabe a parte
burocrática e acaba e acabam se
enriquecendo com dinheiro de pessoas
pretas é como se o mundo das
oportunidades simplesmente não falasse o
mundo das pessoas que mais precisam
delas e É nesse momento que entram as
pessoas do lugar do meio
e quem vive no lugar do meio é capaz de
romper essas bolhas estabelecer Pontes
finalmente unir Dois Mundos e fazer da
nossa sociedade um lugar mais justo
igualitário
para apresenta a minha irmã a gente
descobriu que o Nosso propósito é ser
força motriz para esses artistas super
talentosos negros e de Periferia que tem
muitos sonhos como que a gente teve mas
que de alguma forma não tiveram pessoas
para alimentar esses sonhos e ajudar a
realizá-los Então é isso que a gente se
propõe a fazer
e hoje eu me sinto muito sortuda digitar
nesse lugar do Meio um lugar de
construir pontes um lugar de intercessão
e um lugar de oportunidades que eu quero
que não sejam mais só minhas ou de duas
pessoas negras ou só de pessoas brancas
que já nascem com o mundo de privilégios
quando o lugar do Meio não existe mais é
um sinal de que não vão existir mundos e
realidades tão distintas que façam uma
criança preta crescer com sentimento de
não pertencimento isso é o que eu desejo
obrigada